hey guys what's up it's my meat today
today today today with today 35 a 30
person here at game let's go pen let's
go
nobody's really cheering over here
what
like there's a bike visit like there's a
plate
7,000 people are outside of Mellon arena
right now 7,000 that's a lot leaving a
little early because
good it Masek in traffic hey I'm sorry
I don't have a computer Oh Bonnell okay
you're right
yeah and we just got yelled at for
leaving early but we're actually gonna
go to the restaurant
what say something
well
we are going to the restroom
I don't think we can you not be up there
we'll watch out for you okay it's really
there's like three four five sorry we're
going to the Marriott
you've resorted to the bar because I
right now
we're really really nervous
you tired Emily be there